JK I hear you wanted to run some Rust
cat in the cloud without having to
manage
servers yes that's right Martin not all
serverless platforms can support rust
but I found one that
[Music]
does welcome to the show JK happy to be
here you worked with cloud computing
across banking Insurance technology and
Mining uh you worked on systems that
receive two requests per day and on
systems that receive two billion
requests per day that's right man so why
did you want to use rust in the cloud
well I heard a lot about rust uh and in
some reading that I've been doing lately
um in some surveys it was found that
rust is the most loved Language by the
by its users so I wanted to try it out
in the cloud um and and being a
serverless Enthusiast I didn't want a
server so um I had to find a way to do
it yeah yes and Russ is not available on
many servess platforms right now that's
right uh it's not it's not available on
on many at all uh it's not a top 10 most
used language so its popularity isn't
quite there and therefore most Cloud
providers don't support it out of the
box um so um I was I went looking for a
way to find
it if only there was a way to run any
code in the
cloud that's right containers can solve
that problem and and with Cloud run we
can run any kind of container
uh without having to manage a server
show me how it's
done okay so here's the source code this
HTTP server is using the hyper web
framework um and as you can see here the
main function here is the entry point to
the
application uh it listens to http
requests and um the um make uh the
service function that runs has a
function which itself takes a service
function uh that function accepts a HTTP
request uh which we call rustless and um
the that rustless function simply
returns a HTTP 200 or a status okay and
the accompanying text in the classic
hello world but I made it a bit more fun
to make it hello
rustlers right like great that's a great
first app uh because yeah once you have
hello rust hello world running then you
can build it out uh to be an API for
your web app or mobile app right
absolutely so all you need is a a Docker
file to build the container um and the
docker file that we've got here uses the
rust based image um what it does is then
it copies over that source code that
we've built into the Container um and
then we Expose and map port 8080 to the
internal containers 8080 Port uh and
then U we build our binary using the
cargo tooling and finally uh we set our
Command to run when the container starts
and that that command is just going to
run the rusus binary that's been
produced as part of the build process
and that sits in the release folder ah
got it and then you need to build the
container that's right right um the the
cloud build um service does that for us
and all we need to do in order for cloud
build to do the work for us is Define a
cloud build yaml and that explains what
cloud build needs to do and the steps it
needs to take to build that artifact the
first step in the cloud build Docker com
the doer file commands that we talked
about previously and then it publishes
the container registry the second step
in the CL In This Cloud build file is to
deploy the service to Cloud run and in
this case we've opted to use us Central
but you could replace the region which
whatever's closest to you finally
there's a substitution section at the
bottom that we've used to be able to
easily swap out service names if we need
to or if we me need to make use of
reusable variables I'll build and deploy
the code
now ah look at it
[Music]
go okay cool look at that the deploy
finished and the builds completed and if
we go to the cloud run uh the cloud
console into Cloud run uh here yep um we
can uh click on this um service here and
then you can see at the top of this page
that there's a URL that's a service URL
so if we click on that
URL uh yep you'll see a browser tab
opens up and bang there's the service um
responding with hello
rustless yeah very nice so what makes uh
rust good for backends like this so rust
um obviously is uh it's a compiled
language so it's uh you end up with a
binary at the end and that means that
you can have that you get a very quick
startup time um and since Cloud run can
scale up very quickly um that means that
you can scale out um to support High
peaky uh demands um because we end up
with a s single binary there's a bit of
Simplicity sort of associated with that
um and rust uses a lot less uh memory
and is more efficient with the CPU than
other languages like maybe node or
python um and and with that it means you
have a lower Cloud bill which is um good
for your wallet and finally it's good
for performance critical tasks so things
that need to perform really really fast
or things that need to um uh that rely
on that sort of performance or a high uh
very low latency um rust is a good
option for that I got it and many rust
programs they do sort of number
crunching on the back end like data
science and such so you may not uh want
to or need to trigger your code by HTTP
right oh you don't have to create
trigger your code with HTTP that's right
you can use other types of triggers um
such as um Q's or Cloud run jobs um this
will skip the HTP listener altogether um
and then your jobs on will run your code
um from the beginning all the way
through to the end and then it will just
terminate the container when it's
completed uh you also had to write a
Docker file yeah uh the docker file is
um pretty straightforward the one that
we've used um you can customize
obviously to your heart content um but
this is just a example and so what it
does is it just uses the rust Bas image
uh and it um it would be similar for
most rust services that you'd use um you
may want to use a different bass image
if if you've got some customizations
going on ah right well I just copy and
paste the same dcker file for pretty
much all my nodejs
project yeah well copy paste will get
you some of the way Martin but uh it can
it can be fraught with risk um so for
example Le you know you might have um
some security problems or some some of
the images might have um uh
vulnerabilities in them makes sense so
when working with Docker files I started
to notice some patterns um you know you
can identify the same sort of thing
that's happening on that's happening in
different containers and that sort of
thing um so highly recommend just having
a read through the documentation and um
I discovered that it's not too hard to
write your own Docker file so I want to
play around with your rust program and
maybe add a simple rest API do some
performance testing sure can I download
your code absolutely um I've got a um
GitHub page which has the code that
we've talked about today uh along with a
blog post that'll explain how to get it
all running um and I've had a lot of fun
getting into rust it's um it's fun to
share um what I've been um learning
about uh and I hope you enjoy running it
thank you for showing us JK uh we should
talk more about sess Computing some
other time that would be awesome thanks
very much for having me Martin and thank
you everyone for watching if you have
questions for JK me please add them in
the comment section also let me know if
there are other seress topics you'd like
to hear about in future episodes I read
every single comment until next
[Music]
time